if you're totally successful you're not
fulfilled nothing fulfillment is the
game money can buy you lots of moments
of happiness but it won't buy you
fulfillment the only thing that matters
in life is what you think about yourself
when you're by yourself and have nothing
but your own thoughts rise and shine
it's an espresso time what's up belief
nation it's Evan I believe in you and
this channel is designed to be a part of
your daily success routine so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
find fulfillment over to you Tony
Robbins also if you want to know what
Tony Robbins and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 250
for confidence series where every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join me is
in the description below our strongest
drive is the need to stay consistent
with how we define ourselves so while
you're in this passionate state that's
where you make decisions so if you want
to change your life my friends you got
to change your physiology and you got to
change your focus my goal in the book is
really for people to be happy and more
fulfilled because you have a ton of
money and still be miserable right you
know so it's it's really it's it's like
mastering the science of achievement but
also the art of fulfillment it's about
if you're totally successful you're not
fulfilled then what do you have nothing
yeah you made everybody happy but
yourself you know that's the worst thing
you got that that's Robin Williams is a
beautiful man so it's a beautiful man
killed himself right and he achieved
everything most people have a dream I've
had a beautiful family you've made the
whole world laugh hundreds of million
people loved him but he didn't figure
how to end the suffering money won't do
that fulfilment is the game money can
buy you lots of moments of happiness but
it won't buy you fulfillment to get
fulfillment you need the purpose planner
here's how it works we're looking at
Yahoo
why and your house number one is to whom
and that is your one word your one word
your most important core value when you
know what your who is when you know what
your one word is it allows you to have
strength in your conviction it allows
you to understand this is what I'm all
about
this is my path this is my mission you
might believe something different than
me amazing that means maybe we won't
work together but when you are unclear
with what your most important core value
is then you get swayed by other people's
opinions then when somebody tells you
something if you're standing on
quicksand
you'll take anything just to get out of
the quicksand and you'll be pulled in a
million different directions because
everybody else has an agenda for you the
people around you have an agenda for you
even if it's out of love it's still
their agenda for you and you don't know
what your agenda few even looks like
because you don't know what your core
value is and so that becomes the rock
that you stand on this is what you come
back to and so for me it's belief my one
word is believed it eases out of all of
my content I don't make a video on the
top 10 stupidest things Donald Trump has
said as an example because the negative
video but I'll do a top 10 rules of
success on him as well as the Obamas
Democrats Republicans people from all
walks of life because I think you can
learn from everybody and not everybody
will believe that message or want it
awesome if you don't love believe if
you're not a fan of belief you will you
will hate my channel you will not want
to be here you'll be turned off pretty
much instantly from the content that I
put out and that's great if you don't
like that then we just shouldn't be
coexisting in the same same path right
now that's fine I want people to
self-select
out but the people who love believes the
people who love the message to people
who want that daily motivation in their
lives it's great like let's let's keep
running this parallel path together
forever and so when you understand what
you're one where it is then it allows
you to clear that path it allows you the
certainty understand that these are the
kinds of things that I love doing this
is the kind of person that I am that I
want to be and that's what I'm gonna
live up to it becomes the lens through
which you see your entire world when you
figure that out you have a lot more
confidence clarity and conviction and
when you don't know what it is you fall
for what the people around you want you
to do so step one figure out your who
your one word most important core value
okay that's your who step two is your
why in your why you want to figure out
why you
what you do why you want to be doing
important work in your life and I'm a
big believer that people are built to
serve that all humans are built to serve
that you want to do good that your
happiness will come by helping other
people and why you do it because of some
pain that happen in your life
your purpose comes from your pain and so
the bigger pain that you had in your
life the more powerful a purpose that
you have and so if you think about what
are the moments that happen in your life
that you never want to have happen again
what is the most painful moment in your
life that happened to you that you would
never want your kids to have to go
through and whatever that moment is
that's your purpose maybe you figured
out how to deal with it maybe you're
still dealing with it right now and
that's okay the journey of finding it is
fine the journey of finding the answer
is okay but even showing your journey
and the willingness to go on that
journey that's courageous and that is
your purpose and that will inspire other
people who are currently going through
the thing that you went through to take
action as well and so for me I struggled
so much as an entrepreneur I was making
$300 a month I hated my life I felt
worthless I was too embarrassed and
ashamed to talk to my friends about it
it was it was really the worst part of
my entire life and so it's why I love
helping entrepreneurs because I don't
want anybody to have to go through the
feelings that I went through and so
that's why I love doing what I do
believe is my one word but I could be
believing in anybody why help
entrepreneurs because your purpose comes
from your pain and the most painful
moment in my life was when I told my
business partner that I quit and I felt
like a worthless piece of garbage and so
I don't want other people to have to
feel that and so whatever the most
painful moment in your life is instead
of running away from it instead of being
optimistic and saying life is amazing it
is but recognize that that really sucked
that thing that happened in your life
and now you can help other people who
are currently going through that same
thing too so your purpose comes from
your pain step 2 you have to find your
why okay so the who the why and now the
how step 3 is the how how are you going
to go out and actually accomplish that
and so let's break me down my my who was
believed my one word is believe is what
I stand for as a human being my why my
purpose comes from my pain I want to
help entrepreneurs now there's a lot of
different ways to help entrepreneurs how
do I actually do it I could be making
videos like this I could be meeting
people one-on-one it could be a coach
organs
I could write books I could help you you
know hire a team I could help you move
offices like if you needed help moving
your office and we were renting a truck
and I came as a truck driver and moved
your piano from your home to your office
because you're making it big now and
your office needs a piano I'm helping
you right I'm helping you it part of my
why but I don't enjoy the how and so the
difference here is this is what makes
people successful the difference is you
have to enjoy the process and not just
the end result and so the end result may
be that I believed in you and that I
helped you get a result and that I'm
helping you as an entrepreneur and
that's what I love doing and so I love
that I helped you I love that I had an
impact I love that now you're happy I
love that you're off chasing your big
dreams and goals now but I didn't like
the process I don't like the process of
moving things I don't want to have to
cure piano on my back to your new office
and so you have to enjoy the how you
have to enjoy the process and so if you
make a list right now of all the things
that you've done for people make a list
all the things that you've done for
people that represent your one word that
tie into your most important core value
that comes from the pain that you've
been through how can you help other
people go through the pain that you have
been through they're currently going
through that pain right now how have you
helped them in the past or how would you
like to help them and then look at that
list and see do you actually enjoy the
process of doing that work and not just
the result of helping them so I like
making videos I like researching videos
and like watching videos I like this if
we didn't like it I'd move on and do
something else in my Instagram lives I
love helping people one on one and I
want to broadcast that so that lots of
other people can learn and benefit from
it as well so you have to love the
process and so if you make that list of
all the things that you love doing while
you're helping other people that ends up
giving you the awesome metric the
awesome lens through which you can then
make your final decision figure out your
purpose finalize the purpose planner
when you've gone through your who your
why and you
and so fulfillment is the game it's not
just about making money if you're
providing value to people and you're
fulfilled that's the actual game by
providing value to people you will make
money but you have to be fulfilled in
the process and hopefully the purpose
planner gives you the tools to do it
I've got a really special bonus clip for
you that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that question of the day I want
to know your answers
what are your purpose planner what's
your who what's your why what's your how
putting down comments below looking
forward to seeing your answers
one thing I want to make really clear
and if you ignore everything else this
is the one where you stop and you pay
attention because this could save years
of your life the game you're playing is
not success the game you're playing is
not money the game you're playing is
brain chemistry the only thing that
matters in life truly the only thing
that matters in life is what you think
about yourself when you're by yourself
and have nothing but your own thoughts
if in that moment you feel good about
who you are who you're becoming what
you're capable of and what you're
willing to do to make a better future
for yourself those you care about and
other people around you you will love
your life it is the single most
pleasurable neuro chemical state is deep
fulfillment okay not happiness a bowl of
ice cream brings me a lot of happiness
but it is a very transient experience
deep and lasting fulfillment matters and
what that comes down to is how you feel
about yourself when you're by yourself
you realize along the way or once you've
won something or once you've made a lot
of money it's like if you don't enjoy
the journey that moment is so fleeting
it's it's gone in a second and if you
don't have the inner mindset of loving
yourself of loving who you are of loving
what you do of wanting to make an impact
of wanting to help others of wanting to
improve someone else's life like that
it's honestly the most empty feeling if
you think that's the only thing and I
remember I had this moment I had worked
so incredibly hard it had been like six
years of competing some people some
people compete and win right away and
they get these covers and you know
that's just what I thought would happen
and six years later I'm still like not
winning not getting covers not nobody's
noticing me and finally actually that
year something shifted for me that the
year that I won like swept everything
and what happened is the year prior to
that I had started
training other people go figure training
them for stage really training them a
lot in my studio really wanting other
people to win like making their wins my
win and what happened is their journey
became so much mine and I became so just
immersed in making someone else's life
better that that next year it was like I
was so fulfilled and happy and that just
radiated I knew that my purpose wasn't
just the body I knew that my purpose was
so much bigger than this one thing that
all of a sudden I showed up on stage is
a totally different person literally
people were like who are you what
happened and I had this moment of I I
let go of thinking this was everything
and I actually learned that the journey
is about helping other people it's about
you know really loving what you do and
who you are but loving the fact that you
get to do what you love for other people
and that just it flipped it literally
flipped on a dime for me and that that
was a moment of wow it's never about the
titles those things are amazing don't
get me wrong I love them I'm not gonna
lie but if you don't do both if you
don't use them or use them as a platform
for something they're gonna be really
empty because they're just a moment if
you had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be like a little beacon if
you want more Tony Robbins check out his
eight pieces of life changing and advice
video that we made the link is right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
Impossibles not a fact it's an opinion I
had no money had a 1960 Volkswagen I
worked $40 a week as a janitor to buy
and pay for